This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. One summer a few years ago, Alex Morrow was visiting friends in Berlin. And he made plans to go out to one of the city's most famous techno clubs, a place called Burakine. The club is notoriously difficult to get into. And so Alex made sure he looked just right. They said like, where black so I was wearing everything black. Like black t-shirt, black jeans, black socks. I said, you know, it's just in case I wear black underwear as well.
这里是“99%隐形”。我是罗曼·马尔斯。几年前的一个夏天，亚历克斯·莫罗去柏林看望朋友。他计划去这座城市最著名的 techno 俱乐部之一，一个叫做伯拉罕的地方。这家俱乐部以极难进入而闻名。因此，亚历克斯确保自己的打扮恰到好处。他们说，穿黑色，所以我浑身上下都是黑色的。黑T恤、黑牛仔裤、黑袜子。我说，你知道的，以防万一我还穿了黑内裤。
Even with the black underwear, Alex didn't think much of his chances, but the doorman waved him through. And all of a sudden you're in this environment where the music is penetrating you and I was just like, wow. The club is in a former power plant, and it still has that rough and industrial look that's reported Kevin Caner's, who lives in Berlin.
尽管穿着黑内裤，亚历克斯对自已能进去并没有抱太大希望，但看门人还是挥手让他进去了。突然之间，你置身于这样一个环境中：音乐穿透了你的身体，我当时的感觉就是，哇。这家俱乐部位于一座前发电厂内，它仍然保留着那种粗犷的工业外观，这是居住在柏林的凯文·卡纳斯报道的。
It's a huge hall with massively high ceilings and different floors. And filling the building, of course, is a sound of techno pumped out through an enormous wall of speakers. It was just the sound, and I just got fully into it. Alex lives in London and he'd been clubbing there plenty of times, but this was something different. Everyone can do their thing as long as everyone respects each other. If you see someone naked dancing next to you, cool. If you see someone wearing a suit, cool.
这是一个巨大的大厅，拥有极高的天花板和不同的楼层。当然，充满整个建筑的是通过巨大扬声器墙轰鸣出的 techno 音乐。这就是声音，我完全沉浸其中了。亚历克斯住在伦敦，他在那里去过很多次俱乐部，但这完全是另一回事。只要每个人都互相尊重，所有人都可以做自己。如果你看到有人赤身裸体在你旁边跳舞，很酷。如果你看到有人穿着西装，很酷。
If people are having sex, okay. And I could have done whatever I wanted in that club, but I made my decision to just dance. 14 hours later, Alex was still dancing. It was like he'd been put into some kind of trance. And I danced until about six in the morning. Now's my trip. It was a very joyous, introverted experience for me. Now, Alex tries to come back to Berlin every year, in large part to visit the clubs, and there are millions of people like him. Berlin has become a destination for techno fans from all over the world.
如果有人在做爱，好吧。我完全可以在那家俱乐部里做任何我想做的事，但我决定只是跳舞。14个小时后，亚历克斯还在跳舞。就好像他进入了一种某种形式的催眠状态。我一直跳到早上六点左右。这就是我的旅程。对我来说，这是一次非常快乐、内向的体验。现在，亚历克斯每年都试图回到柏林，很大程度上是为了去那些俱乐部，像他这样的人有数百万。柏林已经成为了世界各地 techno 迷的目的地。
In this music scene that the city is most famous for, it developed because of the thing the city is most infamous for. The Berlin Wall that divided the city into East and West for almost 30 years. Germany was divided at the end of World War II, and so was the city of Berlin. East Berlin was socialist and controlled by the Soviet Union.
在这个这座城市最著名的音乐场景中，它的发展源于这座城市最臭名昭著的事物。将这座城市分割为东西柏林近30年的柏林墙。二战结束时德国被分裂了，柏林市也是如此。东柏林是社会主义的，由苏联控制。
West Berlin, on the other hand, was capitalist. It was a strange island outpost of democratic West Germany that was floating in the middle of socialist East Germany. Then, in 1961, the city became divided not only politically but physically as well. The East German government built a huge wall with checkpoints to prevent its citizens from fleeing into the West. And soon, divided by a wall and living under completely different political and economic systems, two distinct cities emerged, each with its own unique culture and music scene.
另一方面，西柏林是资本主义的。它是飘浮在社会主义东德中间的一座奇怪的、民主西德的岛屿前哨。然后，在1961年，这座城市不仅在政治上，而且在物理上也分裂了。东德政府修建了一堵巨大的墙并设有检查站，以防其公民逃往西方。很快，在一堵墙的分割下，生活在完全不同的政治和经济体系下，两个截然不同的城市诞生了，每个城市都有其独特的文化和音乐场景。
Yes, hello, my name is Mark Reader. I'm British, now German. Musician and record producer Mark Reader was a young man from Manchester. When he came to West Berlin, 17 years after the wall was built, and he immediately fell in love with this strange divided city.
是的，你好，我叫马克·里德尔。我是英国人，现在是德国人。音乐家兼唱片制作人马克·里德尔曾是来自曼彻斯特的年轻男子。当他来到西柏林时，柏林墙修建已经17年了，他立刻爱上了这座奇怪的分裂城市。
What I found was a city that was like, unlike anywhere I've ever been before. I was like, wow, what's this? I have to stay a few more days. For most West Germans, West Berlin was not considered an attractive place to live. There was hardly any industry, and you were essentially cut off
我发现的是一座与我以前去过的任何地方都不同的城市。我当时想，哇，这是什么？我得再呆几天。对大多数西德人来说，西柏林并不被认为是一个适合居住的有吸引力的地方。这里几乎没有什么工业，你基本上被隔绝了。
from the rest of West Germany, surrounded by a wall on all sides. And so eager to attract people to the city, the West German government dangled a few incentives to get people to move there. The first was money. The city was heavily subsidized because it wanted to be attractive. Food was cheap, rents were really cheap.
与西德其余部分隔绝，四面环墙。因此，为了吸引人们来到这座城市，西德政府抛出了一些激励措施来让人搬到那里。首先是钱。这座城市得到了大量补贴，因为它想变得有吸引力。食物很便宜，房租真的很便宜。
I paid for my hovel up to 80 marks a month, which is 40 euros today. The second incentive was that if you lived in West Berlin, you were exempt from the otherwise mandatory military service in West Germany. You know, if you didn't want to be drafted into the West German army, you could go to Berlin and then you were exempt from the army. All of this made West Berlin a haven for misfits, hippies, queer people, and artists of all kinds. So anybody who was kind of weird or didn't fit into what was perceived as West German society, you went to Berlin and you met everybody who was just like you. West Berlin became
我那间陋室的租金最高每月80马克，相当于今天的40欧元。第二个激励措施是，如果你住在西柏林，你就可以免除西德原本强制性的兵役。你知道，如果你不想被征召进西德军队，你可以去柏林，这样你就可以免服兵役。所有这一切使得西德B成为不合群者、嬉皮士、酷儿以及各种艺术家的避风港。所以任何有点奇怪或不符合被认为的西德社会的人，你都会去柏林，并遇到和你一样的人。西柏林成为了。
a place where you could experiment. The artistic side of the city was kind of really off the wall. You could do whatever you liked and no one kind of questioned that because we were all in the same boat. West Berlin hadn't really been known as a musical city. It was known for its wall and it's called War Politics. But by the early 1980s, with these new arrivals, an eclectic scene started to develop. Although just like little clubs and bars started to open, it just kind of started to manifest itself into something which was really a proper scene. On any given night you could hear disco or hip-hop or new wave music and then there was the experimental rock scene full of a constantly changing lineup of bands.
一个你可以进行实验的地方。这座城市的艺术面非常离经叛道。你可以做任何你喜欢的事，没有人会对此质疑，因为我们都在同一条船上。西柏林其实并不以音乐之城闻名。它以柏林墙和冷战政治而闻名。但到了20世纪80年代初，随着这些新来者的加入，一种兼收并蓄的场景开始形成。虽然只是零星的小型俱乐部和酒吧开始开业，但它逐渐演变成了一种真正的场景。在任何一个晚上，你都可以听到迪斯科、嘻哈或新浪潮音乐，然后还有充满不断更换阵容的乐队的实验摇滚场景。
In West Germany they called it the Belly Neckranckheit height, yeah, building illness, because it was so unconventional. It was kind of just kind of this crazy rock music thing. And it was, it was a thrill. But while people like Mark were playing in bands and throwing parties in West Berlin, just behind the wall in East Berlin, it was a completely different world. In socialist East Germany, music was viewed as a potential danger to the state and was heavily regulated. The only publisher of music was the government run label. They
在西德，他们称之为建筑病，是的，建设带来的疾病，因为它是如此非传统。这算是一种疯狂的摇滚乐。而且，这非常刺激。但正当像马克这样的人在西柏林组乐队、开派对时，就在东柏林墙的另一边，那是完全不同的世界。在社会主义东德，音乐被视为对国家的潜在威胁，并受到严格监管。唯一的音乐出版商是国营唱片公司。他们。
didn't allow anything subversive. Oh my, my, aktiv zu werden. Musste man eine Anscheinmache machen? Also eine. Folle Neugabauer lived in East Berlin back in the 1980s. Und he says if you wanted to be a DJ, you had to be officially trained and licensed by the state. The same was true if you wanted to own an electric guitar
不允许任何颠覆性的东西。噢，天哪，变得积极起来。必须得伪装一下吗？也就是一种。福勒·诺伊鲍尔在20世纪80年代生活在东柏林。他说，如果你想成为一名DJ，你必须接受国家的官方培训并获得执照。如果你想拥有一把电吉他，情况也是如此。
or perform in a band. And you couldn't just hold a private dance party. Folle said that also, required official approval. It was actually not private. And Tansen, the discotheque, was only organized by the government. There were still parties though. Vola, for example, got a job helping to organize dances
或在乐队中表演。而且你不能随随便便举办私人舞会。福勒说，这也需要官方批准。实际上这并不私密。迪斯科舞厅的蹦迪，只能由政府组织。不过还是有派对的。比如，沃拉找到了一份工作，协助组织东德官方社会主义青年组织的舞会。但他说，这里面有疯狂的官僚作风。
for the official socialist youth organization of East Germany. But he says there was a crazy bureaucracy. You would have to navigate to make one of these parties happen. First, you'd have to explain to the powers that be exactly what you would be doing and what political and cultural goals you hope to achieve. So Valla would write up an official justification, something along the lines of we're helping to make the youth better socialists through the ecstasy of music. of we're helping to make the youth better socialists through the ecstasy of music.
你要应付这些才能办成一场派对。首先，你得向当权者确切解释你要做什么，以及你希望达到什么政治和文化目标。因此，沃拉会写一份官方的申明，大意是通过音乐的狂喜，我们正在帮助青年成为更好的社会主义者。通过音乐的狂喜，我们正在帮助青年成为更好的社会主义者。
The application would wind its way through official channels and often months later, you'd be approved to host one of these dances. Everything in East Germany took its time. So two different berlins, West and East, meet as a part, but inhabiting stockly different realities, both musically and culturally.
这份申请会在官方渠道中层层审批，通常几个月后，你才会获准举办其中一场舞会。东德的一切都需要时间。所以两个不同的柏林，西柏林和东柏林，作为一部分相遇，却生活在截然不同的现实中，无论是在音乐上还是在文化上。
But while they couldn't take part in West Berlin's club and music scenes, many East Berliners like Walla knew about it, and that's because they could pick up the West Berlin radio stations which beamed over the wall. Yeah, you've heard so much. That's the trash can mix in Studio 92 4 ist. Schäpert's immer. One Show in particular, was SF beat, with Monika Detel. Und aus der Hauste ist das, das ist halt im Monika Detel und losgehen tut's so, wie alles losgeht. Also...
但是，尽管他们无法参与西柏林的俱乐部和音乐场景，许多像瓦拉这样的东柏林人对此有所耳闻，那是因为他们可以收听跨越柏林墙传过来的西柏林广播电台。是的，你听说了太多。那是Studio 924的垃圾桶混音。总是在播放。有一个节目尤其是，那是带有莫妮卡·德特尔的SF beat。从屋里传出来的，这就是莫妮卡·德特尔的节目，开始就像所有事情开始那样。那么……
Every Saturday night, Monika would play acid-house music, which had started becoming popular in West Berlin. The music was electronic, repetitive and perfect for dancing. And during these shows, Monika would often say where this music was being DJed live. She'd say come tonight to the UFO club if you want to party. And all these kids and the Eastay, they know, that there's a massive techno scene happening in West Berlin. And imagine this kind of like club thing that happened there.
每周六晚上，莫妮卡都会播放酸性浩室音乐，这种音乐在西柏林开始流行起来。这种音乐是电子的、重复的，非常适合跳舞。在这些节目中，莫妮卡经常会说这些音乐在哪里有现场打碟。她会说，如果你想狂欢，今晚就来UFO俱乐部。所有这些年轻人和东德人，他们都知道，在西柏林有一个大规模的 techno 场景正在发生。想象一下那里发生的这种俱乐部派对。
No idea what a club thing was, because they just heard the music. But even though the UFO club that Warnica most often mentioned was only 100 meters from the border, it was completely out of reach for Vala. For him, West Berlin felt so inaccessible. It might as well have been the moon. But that was about to change. Beginning in the mid 1980s, Mikhail Gorbachev became the new leader of the Soviet Union. In the mid-1980s, Mikhail Gorbachev became the new leader of the Soviet Union. Gorbachev favored an approach called Glassnost, the Russian word for openness. He was much less authoritarian than earlier leaders, and he started allowing for more transparency
根本不知道什么是俱乐部派对，因为他们只听过音乐。但尽管瓦妮卡最常提到的UFO俱乐部距离边界只有100米，对瓦拉来说却是完全遥不可及的。对他来说，西柏林感觉是那么触不可及。它简直就像是月球。但这即将改变。从20世纪80年代中期开始，米哈伊尔·戈尔巴乔夫成为了苏联的新领导人。在20世纪80年代中期，米哈伊尔·戈尔巴乔夫成为了苏联的新领导人。戈尔巴乔夫赞成一种被称为“公开性”的方法，这是俄语中“开放”的意思。他比前任领导人远没有那么独裁，他开始允许更多的透明度。
in descent. The main achievement of Gorbachev's policies was that in the space of the year or two, he made the fear disappear as if by magic. The East German government was being put under more and more pressure by its own citizens to make similar changes. Man wurde auch mutig. Mutiger. Und hat auch. Ich getraut etwas zu sagen.
和异见。戈尔巴乔夫政策的主要成就在于，在一两年的时间里，他让恐惧如魔法般消失了。东德政府正受到本国公民越来越大的压力，要求其做出类似的改变。人们也变得勇敢了。更勇敢了。而且也。敢于说出一些话了。
Follas says people were becoming braver and more willing to speak out. By the fall of 1989, there were increasingly large public demonstrations taken place, something that until recently would have been unthinkable. In Volos says there was a growing sense among citizens that they might be able to actually change things. But when the Berlin Wall fell, in November 1989, Walla says it still came as a complete and utter shock. He says he can still remember the night very clearly.
福拉说，人们变得更加勇敢，更愿意直言不讳。到了1989年秋天，越来越大规模的公众游行正在发生，这在不久前是不可想象的。沃洛斯说，公民中有一种越来越强烈的感觉，即他们可能真的能够改变现状。但当柏林墙在1989年11月倒塌时，瓦拉说这仍然是一个彻底而完全的震撼。他说他仍然能非常清晰地记得那个夜晚。
He and his girlfriend had been out at a party when they decided to call it a night. When they got home, he turned on the TV and they saw the news. When they got home, he turned on the TV and they saw the news. The first German founds him with the August season. The German Burgers had a symbol for the German and Berlin's had been made. The Maoists were the eight and twenty. What they learned was that the East German border guards gathered at the border crossings were simply letting people through to West Berlin. Suddenly, there were no more controls. And although it wasn't clear what exactly was happening,
他和女友在一个派对上玩得很晚，决定结束当天的行程。回到家后，他打开电视，看到了新闻。回到家后，他打开电视，看到了新闻。第一位德国人……德国公民有了……柏林墙被推倒了。毛派们是八二十。他们了解到的是，聚集在边境口岸的东德边防卫兵只是让人们通过前往西柏林。突然之间，不再有控制了。虽然还不清楚究竟发生了什么，
Wallace's feeling was, finally, we can visit the moon. Finally, we can see for ourselves all the things we've only heard about. He said to his girlfriend, let's go to the West. So they went to the border, and with thousands of others, they crossed over into West Berlin. Yeah, that's why I'm living in a moment. They bought a bottle of champagne from a gas station, and went to look for a friend that even went to the Western side. In the days and weeks that followed,
瓦拉的感觉是，终于，我们可以去月球了。终于，我们能亲眼看到所有我们只听说过的事情了。他对女友说，我们去西方吧。于是他们前往边境，与成千上万的人一起，越境进入了西柏林。是的，这就是我生活在一个时刻的原因。他们在加油站买了一瓶香槟，去找一个甚至去了西方一侧的朋友。在接下来的几天和几周里，
everyone was euphoric and parties started happening everywhere. Right at the very beginning, right after the fall of the wall, the first thing that people wanted to do was go out clubbing. They wanted to visit the clubs they'd heard so much about on the radio. Follow was filled with an enormous sense of freedom and possibility. He says suddenly, everything that had been so strictly regulated, including music, was now open. For the first time these kids and these had the opportunity to choose what kind of music
每个人都欣喜若狂，派对到处都在举行。就在刚开始的时候，就在柏林墙倒塌后，人们想做的第一件事就是去夜店。他们想去参观那些他们在收音机里听说过很多次的俱乐部。福洛心中充满了巨大的自由感和可能性。他说，突然之间，所有曾经受到严格监管的事物，包括音乐，现在都开放了。这些年轻人第一次有机会选择什么样的音乐。
they wanted to listen to. It wasn't music which was being dictated to them by the state of East Germany. This was music that they could decipher themselves. And the fall of the wall happened to occur at a moment when music was going in a brand new direction. The acid house scene of Berlin was quickly moving towards what's known as Tecno, a darker, more propulsive style of music created by black electronic musicians in Detroit. The harder Detroit sound had a huge influence on European musicians, especially the die Musik, kreated by Black electronic musicians in Detroit. Die Harder Detroit Sound hat eine Huge Influence an European musicians, especially the Germans.
他们想听什么。这不是由东德国家向他们发号施令的音乐。这是他们可以自己解读的音乐。柏林墙的倒塌恰好发生在音乐走向全新方向的时刻。柏林酸性浩室音乐场景迅速转向被称为 techno 的音乐，这是一种由底特律黑人电子音乐家创作的更黑暗、更具推进力的音乐风格。更硬核的底特律之音对欧洲音乐家产生了巨大影响，尤其是由底特律黑人电子音乐家创作的音乐。更硬核的底特律之音对欧洲音乐家产生了巨大影响，尤其是德国人。
Und ein paar Wochen nach Wallfell war die neue Harder-Sounds und eine Small-Party an die UFO-Klaus. Diese Musik war reinelektronisch, kalt, hart, als sie, das Musik war hart, driving and psychedelic.
在柏林墙倒塌几周后，新的硬核之音和一场小型派对来到了UFO俱乐部。这种音乐纯粹是电子的、冰冷的、硬核的，当它响起时，音乐是硬核的、充满驱动力的和迷幻的。
And he knew right away. I knew at the time that this was my music. This is my music. The whole political system had just crumbled. The future felt unwritten and this new techno music fit that sense of newness perfectly. But these techno parties were still relatively small. UFO, the main West Berlin Basement Club where this new music was being played, was tiny. It couldn't hold more than 100 people at a time.
他立刻就知道。我当时就知道这就是我的音乐。这是我的音乐。整个政治体系刚刚崩塌。未来感觉尚未书写，这种新的 techno 音乐完美契合了这种新鲜感。但这些 techno 派对仍然相对较小。UFO，播放这种新音乐的主要西柏林地下俱乐部，非常小。它一次容纳不超过100人。
Valla wanted to organize something bigger, freed from the restrictions of the East German state he wanted to throw huge parties with fog machines and strobe lights and with techno music that would play all night. He called these parties, techno tea parties. And as anyone who was there will tell you, it was on the dance floor that East and West really came together. The unification of Germany happened on the dance floor. It didn't happen in politics until much later. Everybody was on the dance floor together and it didn't matter where you came from, whether you're from the east or the west, how much money you were and what kind of job you had, didn't matter. Everyone was dancing on the same drug to the same music,
瓦拉想要组织更大规模的活动，摆脱东德国家的限制，他想要举办带有烟雾机和频闪灯、整晚播放 techno 音乐的大型派对。他把这些派对叫做 techno 茶话会。正如任何在场的人都会告诉你的那样，正是舞池让东西方真正融合在了一起。德国的统一发生在舞池上。它直到很久以后才在政治上发生。每个人都在舞池里，不管你来自哪里，不管你来自东方还是西方，你有多少钱，你做什么工作，这都不重要。每个人都在同样的药物作用下伴随着相同的音乐跳舞。
on the same plane mentally, and everybody loved each other and we were all unified, you know, in that way. For me personally, I think Techno is definitely the sound of the Berlin Wall going down. You know, it's definitely re-unification sound track. But is the scene exploded? Party organizers faced a problem. They needed bigger and bigger venues
在精神上的同一平面上，每个人都彼此相爱，你知道的，我们在那种方式下都统一了。对我个人而言，我认为 techno 绝对是柏林墙倒塌的声音。你知道的，它绝对是重新统一的配乐。但随着场景的爆发。派对组织者面临一个问题。他们需要越来越大的场地。
to accommodate the growing crowds. And unlike West Berlin, which was cramped and claustrophobic, East Berlin had plenty of space. Everybody was exploring spaces all the time. That's basically what we all did. It was like a sport for people to run around and check out where do we have empty apartments. Their Speakel journalist Tobias Rapp was a teenager from West Germany who had just graduated high school when he decided to move with a friend to East Berlin just a few months after the wall fell. They quickly found a place to squat.
来容纳日益增多的人群。与拥挤且幽闭恐怖的西柏林不同，东柏林有充足的空间。每个人都在一直探索空间。这基本上就是我们所有人所做的。就像人们四处奔跑并查看我们在哪里有空公寓的一项运动。明镜周刊记者托比亚斯·拉普是一名来自西德的青少年，在柏林墙倒塌几个月后，他刚刚高中毕业，决定和朋友搬到东柏林。他们很快找到了一个可以私占的地方。
It was just empty and we went in. It was like a big house. Actually, an entire apartment building. So all in all, it was like 30 units? That's how this went down. It did. Pretty basic. Empty building.
那里只是空着，我们就进去了。就像一座大房子。实际上，整栋公寓楼。所以总共大约有30个单元？事情就是这样发生的。确实如此。非常基础。空建筑。
Get it. For Tobias, the whole city was like a big playground of derelict buildings. It wasn't just the abandoned apartments. There were also former military sites and factories that have been shut down and buildings that have been condemned. You're in a huge space, you know, you just discovered it. It's empty. You open up the door, you enter a building, it looks fantastic and it's empty. Nobody asks any questions. So you have to ask yourself a question, what do I do with it?
搞定。对托比亚斯来说，整个城市就像一个废弃建筑的大游乐场。不仅仅是被废弃的公寓。还有曾经的军事基地、已经关闭的工厂以及被谴责的建筑物。你身处一个巨大的空间中，你知道的，你刚刚发现了它。它是空的。你推开门，走进一栋建筑，它看起来棒极了而且是空的。没有人问任何问题。所以你必须问自己一个问题，我该拿它怎么办？
And the easiest thing to do is our mega party. That's the core impulse where this whole Berlin Nightlife Club scene comes from. Not only were there tons of empty buildings, usually it wasn't even clear who owned them. That's because decades before the Nazis had seized property from Jewish citizens. Then after the war, the communists took away lots of real estate from what they thought were Nazis, or bourgeois class. So you had these multiple layers of expropriations going back decades. Everything was theoretically cleared in the contracts
最简单的事情就是办一场大型派对。这就是柏林整个夜生活俱乐部场景的核心脉冲的来源。不仅有大量的空置建筑，通常甚至不清楚它们属于谁。那是因为几十年前纳粹曾没收犹太公民的财产。然后战后，共产党人从他们认为是纳粹或资产阶级的人那里没收了大量房地产。所以你有这些历经几十年的多层征收。理论上，在导致德国统一的合同中一切都已经厘清了。
that led to the German reunification, but to clear on the ground which property belongs to whom. That took years. And while this chaos of our ownership was a headache for the state and of course for the descendants of the people whose property had been seized, it was a godsend for the underground techno music scene. You know, we had a lot of people from West Berlin who had the experience of making parties
但在地面上弄清楚哪处房产属于谁。这花了几年时间。虽然这种产权混乱让国家以及那些财产被没收的人的后代感到头疼，但对于地下 techno 音乐场景来说，这简直是天赐之物。你知道，我们有很多来自西柏林的年轻人，他们在西柏林有过办派对的经验。
in West Berlin and doing events in West Berlin. They realised like, now we have places we can do parties and we don't have to pay any rent and we don't have to pay any fee. With a huge amount of abandoned space, parties started popping up everywhere, usually just for a night or two, and then moving on somewhere else. At the beginning, it was always like changing locations. It was always, it would just be one of party, one of event, and then never again, kind of
并在西柏林举办活动。他们意识到，现在我们有了可以办派对的地方，而且我们不需要付任何租金，也不需要付任何费用。随着大量废弃空间的出现，派对开始到处涌现，通常只持续一两个晚上，然后又转移到别处。一开始，总是像在不断更换地点。总是，只会是一次性的派对，一次性的活动，然后就再也没有了。
of thing. And you would find out about these parties through Word of Mouth. And sometimes you'd have like secret things where it'd be just like, call this number at this time, and you'd phone him to find out my passing was out. But while all this was fun for the people involved, it can only really happen because Berlin's economy was so messed up, there was all this confusion about the ownership of these old derelict buildings, and there wasn't a lot of demand for them. Many older East Germans struggled to this period. They watched as the whole system they had grown up under collapsed. Sometimes the 90s in Berlin looked so idyllic and, ah, times of freedom and blah, blah, blah. For lots of people, it was not like this at all. They lost their job, they lost their status
这种类型的事情。你会通过口碑发现这些派对。有时你会有类似秘密的事情，比如在特定时间拨打这个号码，你会打电话去弄清楚我的派对在哪里。但虽然这对参与其中人来说很有趣，但这其实只能发生是因为柏林的经济一团糟，关于这些老旧废弃建筑的产权存在着所有这些混乱，而且当时对它们的需求并不大。许多较年长的东柏林人在这个时期苦苦挣扎。他们眼看着自己成长于其下的整个系统崩溃了。有时90年代的柏林看起来如此田园诗般，啊，充满自由的时代，等等等等。对许多人来说，情况根本不是这样的。他们失业了，失去了社会地位。
and they felt overwhelmed by historical development that nobody had seen to come. Entire industries were shut down or sold off, as the East was converted from socialism to capitalism at breakneck speed. Lots of people had their lives completely upturned, while the techno kids had their run of things. Berlin's techno scene might have been just a blip, something that disappeared as the post-wall Euphoria faded, where at not for a guy named Demitri Higamon. Demitri helped trend the city's chaotic underground techno movement into a permanent club scene that would change the landscape and economy of Berlin completely.
他们被谁也没有预料到的历史发展压得喘不过气来。整个产业被关闭或出售，随着东部以惊人的速度从社会主义向资本主义转变。许多人的生活被彻底颠覆，而 techno 少年们却能随心所欲。要不是一个叫德米特里·希加蒙的人，柏林的 techno 场景可能只是转瞬即逝的插曲，随着柏林墙倒塌后的狂热消退而消失。德米特里帮助将这座城市混乱的地下 techno 运动塑造成了一个永久性的俱乐部场景，彻底改变了柏林的景观和经济。
Demitri was a West Berliner, and it was his tiny illegal basement club, the UFO club, that had been at the center of the small club scene in West Berlin. But now that the wall had come down and the techno scene was expanding, he wanted something bigger. And so, with a couple of friends, about a year after the wall fell, he started exploring East Berlin, looking for a larger venue where he could put on his parties. Lots of buildings in East Berlin were empty, but many of the most interesting to explore were those that were right by the now unguarded Berlin Wall. And one day in 1990, while Dimitri was stuck in a traffic jam with two friends right by the former wall, they noticed one of these buildings and thought, why don't we try here?
德米特里是一个西柏林人，正是他那间小型的非法地下俱乐部——UFO俱乐部，曾是西柏林小型俱乐部场景的中心。但现在柏林墙倒塌了，techno 场景正在扩张，他想要更大的空间。因此，他和几个朋友在柏林墙倒塌大约一年后，开始探索东柏林，寻找一个可以举办派对的更大场地。东柏林有很多空置建筑，但最有趣的探索对象之一是那些紧邻现在无人看守的柏林墙的建筑。1990年的某一天，当德米特里和两个朋友在前柏林墙附近遭遇交通堵塞时，他们注意到了其中一栋建筑，并想，为什么不在这里试试呢？
We went there and there wasn't a lovely person with this big, key signal and he let us in. The building was small, concrete and kind of shoddy. It was nothing special. But the elderly maintenance man left them with the keys and then I think they went to check it out a second time, which was when they happened to notice some stairs hidden behind some shelves. These stairs led them down to a massive iron door, beyond which was a strange underground room. We smelled the old air, we touched this old locker and it was mysterious, you know. It was like opening a pyramid.
我们去了那里，有一个手里拿着大串钥匙的可爱的人，他让我们进去了。这座建筑很小，是混凝土的，有点破旧。没什么特别的。但这位年长的维修工留下了钥匙，然后我想他们第二次去查看时，刚好注意到隐藏在一些货架后面的楼梯。这些楼梯把他们带到了一扇巨大的铁门前，门后是一个奇怪的地下室。我们闻到了陈旧的空气，触摸了这些旧储物柜，神秘感十足，你知道的。就像打开了一座金字塔。
and it was mysterious, you know. It was like opening a pyramid. For me, it was completely clear. This space has the quality for something great. What they'd found was an enormous fault filled with safety deposit boxes. It had served as the in-house bank of a grand apartment store called The Vertime. The wall was like one meter thick, you know, and it was just concrete and steel and it
神秘感十足，你知道的。就像打开了一座金字塔。对我来说，一切都非常明朗。这个空间具备了成就伟大事业的潜质。他们发现的是一个装满保险箱的巨大金字塔。它曾是一家名为韦特海姆的大型百货公司的内部银行。墙壁大约有一米厚，你知道的，全都是混凝土和钢筋。
was impossible to break through. The Verteheim had been the largest department store in all of Europe, and while the huge main building had been destroyed by bombing during World War II, this underground vault with its meter-thick concrete walls had survived. They asked the maintenance guy, so who's responsible for the building? And he gave them the East Berlin address of the Bundesfemutgenz-Amp, which was the Federal Property Office. When East Germany joined with West Germany and began transitioning to capitalism, all
根本不可能打破。韦特海姆曾是全欧洲最大的百货公司，虽然巨大主建筑在二战期间的轰炸中被摧毁，但这个拥有厚达一米混凝土墙的地下金库却幸存了下来。他们问维修工，谁负责这栋建筑？他给了他们联邦财产局在东柏林的地址。当东德与西德合并并开始向资本主义过渡时，所有。
the communal property and state-owned industries of the former socialist country had to be sold off or managed in the capitalism. All the communal property and state owned industries of the former socialist country had to be sold off or managed in the meantime. And the address to Meetry had been given was one of the government agencies that have been put in charge of this task. They were unorganized and they said, okay, if this is the address and we work out something for three months, you know, and they told us, you cannot expect that you can stay longer if the owner comes and says, it's mine. But even armed with a three-month lease, Demetri was ecstatic. I was so happy, you know, that I could find in the heart of the Lin-Tis space. They spent the next few months cleaning it up. And in March 1991, they opened up a club.
前社会主义国家的公共财产和国有产业都必须出售或在过渡期间进行管理。德米特里得到的地址是负责这项任务的政府机构之一。他们没有组织纪律，他们说，好吧，如果这是地址，我们商量三个月的租期，你知道的，他们告诉我们，你不能指望如果主人来索要说这是我的，你还能待更久。但即使手里只有一份三个月的租约，德米特里也欣喜若狂。我太高兴了，你知道的，我竟然能在柏林市中心找到这个空间。他们接下来的几个月里将其清理干净。1991年3月，他们开了一家俱乐部。
They called it Tresor, the German word for vault. Now you didn't have to call a secret number to find a techno party. On a Saturday night, you knew exactly where to go. The scene was evolving from fleeting parties and scattered places to something bigger and more established. Large, unusual spaces like Trezor were starting to take hold. Trezor quickly became known for its hard-to-troit large, unusual spaces like Tresor were starting to take hold.
他们叫它 Tresor，这是德语中“金字塔”的意思。现在你不需要拨打秘密号码来寻找 techno 派对了。在周六晚上，你知道该去哪里。场景正从短暂的派对和零星的地点演变成更大、更成熟的东西。像 Tresor 这样的大型、不寻常的空间开始占据主导地位。Tresor 很快以其受底特律启发的硬核派对而闻名。
Tresor quickly became known for its hard, Detroit inspired techno parties that would go all weekend. With the fog machines and strobe lights and loud beads, people seemed to forget time and space. Tresor didn't just help popularize this new, harder version of Detroit's techno sound. It also helped build a real connection between the Berlin and Detroit techno scenes. Dimitri started the Tresor label and began releasing the work of many
大型、不寻常的空间像 Tresor 一样开始站稳脚跟。Tresor 迅速以其硬核、受底特律启发的 techno 派对而闻名，这些派对会持续整个周末。伴随着烟雾机、频闪灯和响亮的节拍，人们似乎忘记了时间和空间。Tresor 不仅帮助推广了底特律 techno 音乐这种更硬核的新版本。它还帮助在柏林和底特律的 techno 场景之间建立真正的联系。德米特里创立了 Tresor 唱片公司，并开始在全欧洲发行许多。
of these Detroit musicians throughout Europe. For many visitors like Tobias, going to Tresor for the first time was like a revelation. I thought, okay, this is our zero. Everything that I used to believe in musically is the past. And I'm right here right now in the present. This boom, boom, boom, that wipes away everything else.
这些底特律音乐家的作品。对许多像托比亚斯这样的访客来说，第一次去 Tresor 就像是一次启示。我想，好吧，这就是我们的零点。我过去在音乐上信仰的一切都已成为过去。而我此时此刻就身处现在。这咚、咚、咚的节奏，抹去了其他一切。
That was my feeling. Trasore's three month lease was extended for another three months and then another. And meanwhile, a whole network of clubs began to develop nearby in the empty buildings right by the former site of the Berlin Wall. And over time, the diagnosing continued to grow and began driving an economic revival in Berlin.
这就是我的感受。Tresor 三个月的租约被延长了另外三个月，然后又延长了。与此同时，一个由俱乐部组成的网络开始在前柏林墙遗址附近的空置建筑里发展起来。随着时间推移，这种诊断持续增长，并开始推动柏林的经济复苏。
The Metrie says people felt empowered to experiment and to use the city's empty spaces in creative ways. Nobody made big plans, we do something for the next 20 years or so. We just said, okay, for one week, that's great for one month or just for one day, let's get together and have a good time. That was the beginning of many, many small startups. People began opening not only clubs, but bars and art galleries and all kinds of small businesses.
德米特里说，人们感到有力量去进行实验，并以创造性的方式利用城市的空置空间。没有人制定什么宏伟计划，我们要搞个未来二十年左右的计划。我们只是说，好吧，为一个星期，这就很棒了，或者为一个月，或者仅仅为一天，让我们聚在一起玩得开心。那是许多许多小型初创企业的开端。人们不仅开始开设俱乐部，还开设酒吧、艺术画廊和各种小企业。
And all of these new businesses could basically fly under the radar. There was so much else going on with the politics of reunifying the city. That for the most part, no one was really checking to make sure anyone was paying taxes or getting the proper permits to put on events or show alcohol. And that was the case for years. In many ways Berlin hadn't had a stable identity since World War II. This idea had been occupied, then divided, and never had much of an industry, plus the shadow of being the capital of Nazi Germany still lingered.
所有这些新企业基本上都可以在雷达底下悄悄运行。当时由于城市重新统一的政治问题，有太多其他事情正在发生。以至于在大多数情况下，真的没有人去检查是否有人在按时纳税或获得了举办活动或出售酒精的适当许可。这种情况持续了多年。在很多方面，自二战以来，柏林一直没有一个稳定的身份。这个想法曾被占领，然后被分裂，从来没有过太多的工业，再加上作为纳粹德国首都的阴影依然挥之不去。
But the new culture that started to grow up around the technocene helped to change that. And as techno migrated from the underground to the mainstream, it began to drop people from all over the world. Word had gotten out. If you like techno and sweaty dance parties that last until dawn, you've got to check out Berlin. You hear that a friend of a friend of a friend of yours tells crazy stories about this crazy club he was to, and then you go and check out for yourself and you realize, hmm, it's really amazing.
但围绕 techno 音乐场景开始成长起来的新文化帮助改变了这一点。随着 techno 从地下走向主流，它开始吸引来自世界各地的人们。消息传出去了。如果你喜欢 techno 和持续到天亮的大汗淋漓的舞派对，你必须要来看看柏林。你听说你朋友的朋友的朋友讲述了关于他去过的这家疯狂俱乐部的疯狂故事，然后你亲自去看看，你意识到，嗯，这真的很神奇。
And the more crazy the stories are, the more power they tend to get. This was helped along by the fact that in the early 2000s, flights within the EU had gotten significantly cheaper. You didn't have to be rich anymore to visit just for a weekend. And while tourists used to come to Berlin for the historical monuments. Where's the wall? Where's the Brunt and Brookgate? Now, they were coming for the clubs.
故事越疯狂，它们往往就越有力量。这得益于2000年代初欧盟内部航班变得明显便宜的事实。你不再需要有钱才能仅仅为了周末来参观。虽然游客过去常常为了历史古迹来到柏林。墙在哪里？布兰登堡门在哪里？现在，他们是为了俱乐部而来的。
Where can I go out? Where are the techno clubs? And over time, some of those travelers decided to stay. And with all the new energy, the nightlife became a real economic force. 2019 generated 1.4 billion euros. That's the only thing that we have in this city is the entertainment industry. And it wasn't just the direct impact of the club scene that was changing the city.
我可以去哪里玩？techno 俱乐部在哪里？随着时间推移，其中一些游客决定留下来。凭借所有的新能量，夜生活成为了一种真正的经济力量。2019年创造了14亿欧元的产值。这是我们在座城市里仅有的娱乐产业。而且改变这座城市的不仅仅是俱乐部场景的直接影响。
There were lots of additional effects as well. Tech companies related to electronic music, like SoundCloud, Ableton, and Native Instruments were founded in Berlin. Other tech companies, not always related to music, followed. And finally, after years of being famously economically challenged, Berlin was growing faster than the rest of Germany. And? I think the influence of techno music and the subcultural nightlife that comes along with it is much, much bigger than anybody imagines. Today, the techno scene is so important economically to the city that even the conservative Christian Democratic Party of Berlin talks about the need to support Berlin's club culture, despite all the drugs and hedonism that it involves.
还有很多连锁效应。与电子音乐相关的科技公司，如 SoundCloud、Ableton 和 Native Instruments，都是在柏林创立的。其他科技公司，不一定与音乐相关，也随之而来。最后，在经历多年著名的经济困境后，柏林的增长速度超过了德国其他地区。而且？我认为 techno 音乐及其伴随的亚文化夜生活的影响比任何人想象的都要大得多。今天，techno 场景对该市的经济如此重要，以至于连柏林保守的基督教民主党也谈到需要支持柏林俱乐部的文化，尽管其中包含所有的毒品和享乐主义。
And just recently, the German federal parliament decided to reclassify nightclubs as cultural institutions, meaning they're granted the same legal status as museums and opera houses. This kind of mainstream recognition can sometimes be weird for the people who were involved with the scene, back when I was just starting, when everything felt wild and subversive and completely new. Techno is 40 years old now, so it has grown up. The people who run the clubs now, they're professionals, they know exactly what they're doing. Most of them are the clubs now, they're professionals. They know exactly what they're doing. Most of them are really smart businessmen.
就在最近，德国联邦议会决定重新将夜总会归类为文化机构，这意味着它们获得了与博物馆和歌剧院相同的法律地位。对于那些在场景刚开始、一切都显得狂野、颠覆且完全崭新的时期参与其中的人来说，这种主流认可有时可能会觉得很奇怪。Techno 现在已经40岁了，所以它已经长大了。现在经营俱乐部的人，他们是专业人士，他们非常清楚自己在做什么。他们中的大多数是俱乐部的经营者，他们是专业人士。他们非常清楚自己在做什么。他们大多数是真正精明的商人。
They know who their audience is. They know that they're not planning just for today, but they're planning for their life, that it's a real career. Which is not how it was back in the 90s. Back then, to be a said, you never really knew what was going to happen next. I'm sometimes nostalgic for the 90s because of the freedom and all the craziness and chaos,
他们知道他们的受众是谁。他们知道他们不仅是在为今天做计划，而且是在为他们的一生做计划，这是一份真正的职业。这和90年代完全不同。那时候，作为一个人说，你永远不知道接下来会发生什么。我有时会因为90年代的自由、所有的疯狂和混乱而怀念那个时期。
but I'm not nostalgic for the Germanness of the 90s. I find this international city that we have now way more attractive than this German city I had back then. And he's just waiting to see what this new international generation of Berliners comes up with. Berlin is a very inviting city and techno is one of these tools that gives out an invitation to the world and says, Hey, you can come here and you can be part of what this city is about to become. is about to become. That story was produced by Kevin Caner's and edited by Delaney Hall. Coming up after the break, we talk with Kevin about the origins of the Detroit techno
但我并不怀念90年代的德国味。我觉得我们现在拥有的这座国际化城市比我当年拥有的那座德国城市更有吸引力。他只是在等待看看这代柏林的新国际化一代会想出什么点子。柏林是一个非常热情好客的城市，techno 是向世界发出邀请的工具之一，它说，嘿，你可以来这里，你可以成为这座城市即将蜕变成的样子的一部分。即将蜕变成的样子。这个故事由凯文·卡纳斯制作，德莱尼·霍尔剪辑。休息过后，我们将与凯文聊聊底特律 techno 场景的起源，以及这种音乐最终如何传到了柏林。
scene and how the music eventually made its way to Berlin. So we're back with Kevin, and you know, Kevin, the story that we just heard was all about Berlin and techno's influence on the city, but we also mentioned how the sound originally came over from Detroit, and that's like a whole other story. Yeah, so Teno first emerged in Detroit in the 1980s, and I was curious about how that happened. So I called up two of the important early techno musicians from Detroit, one Atkins and Blake Baxter. And they both described Detroit in the 80s as a rough place to live.
所以我们和凯文回来了，你知道的，凯文，我们刚刚听到的故事都是关于柏林以及 techno 对这座城市的影响，但我们也提到了这种声音最初是如何从底特律传过来的，这就像是另一个完全不同的故事。是的，所以 techno 最初在20世纪80年代的底特律兴起，我很好奇那是怎么发生的。所以我打电话给两位底特律早期重要的 techno 音乐家，胡安·阿特金斯和布莱克·巴克斯特。他们都把80年代的底特律描述为一个生活艰难的地方。
It was an industrial city that was quickly becoming post-industrial. The population was shrinking. There was a lot of white flight. And people were losing their jobs. Here's Blake Baxter. Detroit was dark. I lived downtown and it was like an
这是一座工业城市，正在迅速转变为后工业城市。人口在萎缩。有很多白人群飞。人们在失业。这是布莱克·巴克斯特。底特律很黑暗。我住在市中心，感觉就像是一座有高耸摩天大楼的废弃城市。我的意思是，六点钟，你在街上看不到任何人。就像店面都关门了，市中心完全空了。所以，是的，70和80年代的底特律是一团糟。嗯，他们周围的城市经济萧条。布莱克和胡安都来自中产阶级黑人家庭。他们说，他们和他们的朋友是一个非常特殊的社交圈子的一部分。他们喜欢各种音乐，包括很多来自欧洲的东西。
abandoned city with tall skyscrapers. I mean, six o'clock, you didn't see no one on the street. Like the storefronts were all closed, totally empty downtown. So yeah, Detroit was a high mess in the 70s and 80s. Well, the city around them was economically depressed. Blake and Juan both came from middle class black families. And they say that they and their friends were part of a very particular social scene. They were into all kinds of music, including a lot of stuff from Europe.
这是胡安。所以他们会办一些派对，你知道的，他们会放迪斯科音乐，还有进口音乐之类的东西。我认为黑人青少年只是喜欢任何好玩、有创意的东西，对我来说，我只是把这一切都吸收进来，试图将它们融合在一起。
Here's Juan. So they would do these parties where you know, they play disco music and tell you import music and you know stuff like that. I think black teens were just like into whatever was good and creative and for me, I was just soaking it all up, trying to incorporate it all.
那么他们都在听什么样类型的东西呢？他到底在说什么？嗯，很多都是电子的或基于合成器的。就像从帕liament、Funkadelic、乔治·莫罗德尔到像 Devo 和 Depeche Mode 这样的新浪潮乐队的一切。他们真的很喜欢德国乐队克拉夫特维克。我们超爱克拉夫特维克。
And so what kind of stuff were they listening to? Like what is he talking about? Well, a lot of it was electronic or synthesizer based. Like everything from Parliament, Fogadelic, and George Euromoroder to new way bands like Devo and DePesh mode. And they really loved the German band, Kraftwerk. We loved Kraftwerk.
那么他们当时都在听些什么音乐呢？他指的是什么？嗯，其中很大一部分是电子乐或合成器音乐。比如从Parliament、Funkadelic和Giorgio Moroder，到像Devo和Depeche Mode这样的新浪潮乐队。他们还非常喜欢德国乐队Kraftwerk。我们太爱Kraftwerk了。
Kraftwerk was one of the main engines that fuel electro and Detroit. Everyone was Kraftwerk. Oh! Oh! I love craftwork, too. It doesn't seem like it's very much like the techno music that we heard in the piece. How did they get from craftwork to what they were creating?
发电厂是推动电子乐和底特律音乐的主要引擎之一。每个人都是发电厂乐队的粉丝。哦！哦！我也很喜欢发电厂乐队。这听起来好像不太像我们在片段中听到的那种技术音乐。他们是怎么从发电厂走到他们所创造的东西的？
Yeah, it does seem like a pretty big leap. So right around the same time, the early 1980s, was when all these new consumer electronic instruments started becoming available. There were new synths from manufacturers like Corg and drum machines like the TR 808 and 909. Sure. And while synths and drum machines had existed before, these new models were cheap enough
是的，这听起来确实是一个相当大的跨越。就在同一时期，即20世纪80年代初，所有这些新型的消费级电子乐器开始问世。有来自科格等制造商的新合成器，还有像TR 808和909这样的鼓机。确实如此。虽然合成器和鼓机以前就存在，但这些新型号足够便宜，
that a lot of people could actually afford them. And this opened up a whole new world for kids like Juan and Blake. It meant that they could make music at home. Yeah, because before that it was like going to a studio, having a drummer play the beats, and then when the 909 came, I made music production affordable. It had everything on it, and it had a big sound too. I would record like a rhythm track on one cassette, then play it back back and record a bass line and catch it on the other cassette. And I will ping pong back and forth to eventually I had a song.
以至于许多人实际上买得起了。这为胡安和布雷克这样的孩子们打开了一个全新的世界。这意味着他们可以在家里制作音乐。是的，因为在那之前，这就好像是去录音室，找个鼓手来打节奏，然后当909出现时，它让音乐制作变得负担得起。它上面什么都有，而且声音也很大。我会把节奏轨录在一盒磁带上，然后放出来，再录贝斯声并录在另一盒磁带上。我会来回反复，直到最终做出了一首歌。
And one in Blake were by no means the only ones. Tons of young kids were experimenting. Every kid, my age, I knew they were doing the same thing, like wanting to make electronic music. Yeah, it just caught on like wow fire. And it just got to a stage where just everybody started making music. The manufacturers made this technology available and we picked it up and ran with it. So there's all these technologies like drum machines and synths. But what was it about Detroit? Like all the musicians and people who are promoting parties in Berlin and your piece,
而胡安和布雷克绝不是仅有的两个人。成群的年轻孩子都在进行实验。我认识的每个同龄孩子都在做同样的事情，比如想要制作电子音乐。是的，它就像野火一样流行开来。而且它发展到一个阶段，每个人都开始制作音乐。制造商让这些技术变得触手可及，我们拿起它就大干了一场。所以有所有这些像鼓机和合成器这样的技术。但底特律究竟有什么特别之处呢？就像你在柏林和你的片段中采访的所有音乐人和派对组织者一样，
are talking about Detroit, like what was distinctly happening in Detroit? Yeah, well, it's not like these machines where instruments were only being used in Detroit. There was also Chicago House music that used these devices like the Roland 808 and 909. But Chicago House music was more influenced by disco and soul music. You know, and there was this really big party scene around Chicago House music,
都在谈论底特律，底特律到底发生了什么与众不同的事情？是的，这并不是说这些机器或乐器只在底特律被使用。当时也有芝加哥浩室音乐在使用罗兰808和909这些设备。但芝加哥浩室音乐受迪斯科和灵魂乐的影响更大。你知道的，围绕芝加哥浩室音乐有着非常盛大的派对场景，
but musicians and Detroit seemed more attracted to harder, more industrial sounds. That was just what Detroit was into from day one, this electro-hard industrial combination. And there was this one Detroit collective in particular called the Underground Resistance. And its founders, Jeff Mills, Robert Herd and Mike Banks were really pioneers of this darker Detroit sound. It was kind of like their city's answer to happier Chicago House music. And this was a distinction that became really clear in 1988. When Virgin Records from the UK decided to put out a compilation album with artists like Blake Baxter and Juan Atkins featuring this new Detroit music.
但底特律的音乐人们似乎更被更硬核、更工业的声音所吸引。这正是底特律从第一天起就喜欢的东西，这种电子-硬核-工业的结合。当时有一个特别的底特律音乐集体叫做“地下抵抗”。它的创始人杰夫·米尔斯、罗伯特·赫德和迈克·班克斯确实是这种更黑暗的底特律之声的先驱。这有点像是他们的城市对更快乐的芝加哥浩室音乐的回应。这种区别在1988年变得非常清晰。当时来自英国的维京唱片公司决定推出一张合辑，收录了布雷克·巴克斯特和胡安·阿特金斯等艺术家的作品，这些作品带有这种底特律的新音乐。
They were going to call that album, the house sound and Detroit. And I submitted the track called a Techno Music. And I said, no, my music is Techno Music. My music can't house music. And so that submission made them change the album to that techno sound to be sure. Wow. Like rarely do you get a moment where you're like, okay, we're going to call everything techno from here on. I mean, that's just great. Yeah, I mean, it's a bit to, I'm clear, if it's like this moment, because in Germany, they also use the word techno, but techno was more like the Pesh mode or like it wasn't like what we think today is techno.
他们本打算把那张专辑叫做“底特律的浩室之声”。我提交了一首名为《技术音乐》的曲子，我说，不，我的音乐是技术音乐。我的音乐绝不可能是浩室音乐。所以这个提交让他们把专辑改成了“那种技术之声”，以确保万无一失。哇。真是难得有这样一个时刻，让你觉得，好吧，从今以后我们要把一切都叫做技术音乐。我的意思是，这真是太棒了。是的，我的意思是，为了弄清楚，这有点像这个时刻，因为在德国，他们也使用“技术”这个词，但技术更像是讨戴灭（佩诗模式），或者说它不像我们今天所认为的技术音乐。
That's interesting. So yeah, so techno, the new dance sound of Detroit came out and helped solidify techno as this unique genre. And is that album how the music made its way over to Europe and Berlin? Well, it certainly helped. But maybe more importantly for Berlin was the fact that there was a record store owner here named Mark Ernestus. And Mark had a really big hand in getting many of these Detroit records over to Berlin and noticed by the DJs here. And so the music comes over, and you also mentioned the piece that musicians eventually came over too, like how did that all happen? Yeah, so much 1991, Trezor opens and quickly becomes known for its love of hard Detroit techno. And already within the first few months of the club's existence, it's owner, Dimitri Hegeman, this is the guy that we met in the main story, he invited many of these pioneering Detroit
这很有趣。所以，是的，技术音乐，底特律的新舞曲风格诞生了，并帮助巩固了技术音乐作为这一独特流派的地位。这张专辑就是音乐传到欧洲和柏林的方式吗？嗯，这确实有帮助。但对柏林来说，更重要的或许是这里有一位唱片店老板名叫马克·恩内斯图斯。马克在将许多底特律唱片带到柏林并受到这里的DJ关注方面发挥了非常大的作用。所以音乐传过来了，你还提到音乐人最终也过来了，这一切是怎么发生的？是的，到了1991年，特雷佐俱乐部开业了，并迅速以对硬核底特律技术音乐的热爱而闻名。在这个俱乐部开业的头几个月里，它的老板德米特里·黑格曼——也就是我们在主故事中遇到的那个人，他邀请了许多这些开创性的底特律
techno artists over to come to Berlin and play Trezor. Juan came, underground resistance came, and Blake came. Berlin was messed up. I mean, it looked like right after the war because the buildings were towed up, the wall was still partially up, but I really loved the look because I came from Detroit. So I always saw Beauty and Decay and just looking at how Berlin was, it was amazing. And so, did they say what it was like playing their music, like across the ocean in this completely different context? Yeah, so it was definitely so much strange for them. When they played at Trezor, it was mostly if not all white crowd at Trezor, whereas in Detroit, the parties we played in Detroit was all black kids.
技术音乐家来到柏林并在特雷佐演出。胡安来了，地下抵抗来了，布雷克也来了。柏林当时一团糟。我的意思是，它看起来就像刚经历过战争一样，因为建筑都被炸毁了，墙还部分矗立着，但我真的很喜欢这种外表，因为我来自底特律。所以我总是能看到废墟中的美，看着柏林的样子，真是太棒了。那么，他们有没有说过在大洋彼岸、在这样一个完全不同的环境中演奏他们的音乐是什么感觉？是的，所以对他们来说这肯定非常陌生。当他们在特雷佐演出时，特雷佐的观众几乎全是白人，而在底特律，我们演出的派对上全都是黑人小孩。
But they say it was also exciting to see the enthusiasm that this other culture had for their music. It was so many more people into what we were into and we were like shocked to see that. And then how they partied in these old dirty spaces, finding old bunkers, old basements, and these loud sound systems. We were doing that in Detroit, but they took it up to a great insane level. Yeah, it was like Detroit on steroids.
但他们说，看到另一种文化对他们的音乐抱有如此高的热情，也是令人兴奋的。有这么多的人对我们所热衷的东西感兴趣，我们看到这一幕都惊呆了。然后他们如何在这些又老又脏的空间里开派对，寻找旧掩体、旧地下室，还有这些大功率的音响系统。我们在底特律也这么做，但他们把它提升到了一个极其疯狂的水平。是的，这就像打了兴奋剂的底特律。
I really loved it. And at least for Blake, he found this kinship between the vibe of Berliners and Detroiters. It seemed like people in Berlin, they were on the same wavelength. You know, Detroit wasn't into formulated sounds. It's like you get a keyboard, you mess it the hell up. You mess up the parameters, the frequencies, and you just find the most tough sound you can and you make it work.
我真的很喜欢它。至少对布雷克来说，他在柏林人和底特律人的氛围中找到了亲近感。柏林人似乎和他们在同一个频率上。你知道的，底特律不喜欢公式化的声音。就像你拿到一把键盘，然后把它彻底搞砸。你把参数、频率全弄乱，然后找到你能找到的最硬的声音，并让它发挥作用。
And the German people, they love experimentation. So it was a great match. And the crazier we got, the more they loved it. He's so good. I mean, obviously, as he mentioned, Detroit had gone through this strange abandonment downtown and difficult times and Berlin was going through this. I mean, is this what he attributes to why they were all on the same wavelength? Yeah, I think so because Detroit had racism and job losses while Berlin had the division
而德国人，他们热爱实验。所以这真是绝配。我们越疯狂，他们就越喜欢。他太棒了。我的意思是，很明显，正如他所提到的，底特律市中心经历了这种奇怪的荒废和艰难时期，柏林也在经历这个。我的意思是，这就是他将他们都在同一频率上的原因归结于此吗？是的，我想是的，因为底特律有种族主义和失业问题，而柏林有分裂
and the war, both really kind of dark, difficult pasts. And Blake says that created a shared desire of the young people in both cities to step out from those shadows. You know, wanting to express yourself and wanting to let go of the past and step into the future, I think that was something being from Detroit and being from Berlin. I think we had that in common. And almost from day one, this bond between these Detroit musicians like Blake and Juan and the city develops into something much more than just coming to play for a night and then leaving.
和战争，两者都有着相当黑暗、艰难的过去。布雷克说，这在两个城市的年轻人中创造了一种共同的愿望，即走出这些阴影。你知道，想要表达自己，想要放下过去，迈向未来，我认为这是来自底特律和来自柏林的共同点。我想我们有这个共同点。几乎从第一天起，布雷克和胡安这些底特律音乐家与这座城市之间的这种纽带就发展成为远不止是来演出一晚然后离开的东西。
And a lot of this was specifically because of Demetri Hagueman. You know, he ended up putting out albums of theirs on the treasure label, and so they stayed to make these albums. So some of the Detroit guys ended up spending a lot of time in the city. And so what was it like for them to go back and forth between the two cities? I mean, well, one kind of difficult part of it was that while Detroit and Berlin were both in rough shape at the beginning of the 90s when they first started coming, one in Blake watched as Berlin started to rebound while things in Detroit stayed pretty much the same. Berlin kind of went leads and bounds,
这在很大程度上正是因为德米特里·黑格曼。你知道，他最终在特雷佐厂牌下发行了他们的专辑，所以他们留下来制作这些专辑。因此，一些底特律人最终在这座城市度过了很长时间。那么，在两个城市之间来回穿梭对他们来说是什么感觉？嗯，其中一个有点困难的部分是，虽然底特律和柏林在90年代初刚开始来往时都处于艰难时期，但胡安和布雷克看着柏林开始复苏，而底特律的情况却几乎保持原样。柏林简直是突飞猛进，
past Detroit since then. I mean, when the first time I went, it was like it looked around the same size of Detroit, kind of bleak cold all the time. Then the next time I came, the year or two after, it's like the sky was full of cranes. Like everywhere you look in Berlin, there was cranes.
把底特律甩在身后。我的意思是，当我第一次去的时候，它看起来和底特律差不多大，总是那种阴冷萧瑟的感觉。然后我第二次来，也就是那一两年后，天空仿佛全都是起重机。就像你在柏林无论往哪看，都有起重机。
And now you don't even recognize the cliffs. So Berlin is rebuilding with all these construction cranes, but the same thing isn't happening in Detroit. Yeah, exactly. And while Berlin is becoming this techno city world famous for its clubs, this was also not happening in Detroit. So this day we don't really have a real purpose bill
现在你甚至认不出那些街区了。所以柏林正伴随着所有这些建筑起重机进行重建，但底特律却没有发生同样的事情。是的，完全如此。正当柏林成为以俱乐部闻名世界的“技术音乐之都”时，底特律却没有发生这种情况。直到今天，我们实际上都没有一个真正专为技术音乐建造的
club for technology, and Detroit, above all places. And Blake and Juan say that while the Berlin government sees the value in the nightlife and its club scene, the city of Detroit doesn't view it nearly as favorably. And of course, unlike Berlin, where there's no curfew, and you can sell drinks all night, Detroit has a last call of 2 a.m. Which makes it far harder to open up a financially successful club. Again, I have the three-day parties that you talk about if you have to close down at 2 a.m.
俱乐部，而底特律本该是最适合的地方。布雷克和胡安说，虽然柏林政府看到了夜生活及其俱乐部场景的价值，但底特律市对它的态度并没有那么青睐。当然，与柏林不同的是，柏林没有宵禁，你可以整晚卖酒，底特律的最后点单时间是凌晨2点。这使得开设一家财务上成功的俱乐部变得困难得多。再说一次，如果你必须在凌晨2点关门，你怎么能举办你所说的那种三天三夜的派对呢？
But are there other efforts to change that to sort of to to in live in the techno scene and Detroit? Yeah, so for a while now Dimitri Higman has been involved in efforts along with local Detroiters to bring more of a nightlife economy to the city. As we talked about in the first half of the show, he's a strong believer in how the night culture has helped Berlin and its economy, and he thinks at least to a degree it could do the same for Detroit. So he's visited Detroit many times over the years and worked with local politicians there to see how they can bring more clubs to the city.
但是有没有其他努力来改变这种状况，比如复苏底特律的技术音乐场景？是的，一段时间以来，德米特里·黑格曼一直与当地底特律人一起努力，为这座城市带来更多的夜生活经济。正如我们在节目前半部分所讨论的那样，他坚信夜生活文化如何帮助了柏林及其经济，他认为至少在某种程度上，它也可以对底特律起到同样的作用。因此，这些年来他多次访问底特律，并与那里的当地政治家合作，看看如何能为这座城市带来更多的俱乐部。
So I said, let's try it out. Let's make an experiment. Let's get an art zone, an zoned area where the venues open till six in the morning or eight. Because you lose the night and the night is an important time. It made Berlin very popular and attractive, and it would create a lot of jobs. A lot of jobs, you know. They have space. What city has space, you know?
所以我说，让我们试试看。让我们做一个实验。让我们设立一个艺术区，一个营业到清晨六点或八点的特许区域。因为你失去了夜晚，而夜晚是一个重要的时刻。它让柏林变得非常受欢迎和迷人，并且会创造很多工作岗位。很多工作岗位，你知道的。他们有空间。哪个城市有空间，你知道吗？
And it's still available, I think. Hmm, that's fascinating. And so what do Blake and Juan think about these efforts to create this nightlife mecca and Detroit? Well, they both are pretty positive and think it's a good idea, but also acknowledge that there are definite hurdles standing in the way. The problem is the amount of people. See Berlin has way more people living in the inner city and way more young people going
而且它仍然可用，我想。嗯，这太迷人了。那么布雷克和胡安对这些在底特律打造夜生活圣地的努力有何看法？嗯，他们都非常积极，认为这是一个好主意，但也承认前方确实存在障碍。问题是人口数量。你看，柏林内城居住的人口要多得多，出去玩的年轻人也
out than Detroit has. Detroit is still like young in its Renaissance stage. So it can happen and it's a really great concept, but it would take time in a lot of funding, but you know, the matrix, a guy that comes up with ideals and some work, some don't, but when they work, they really work. And people here in Detroit, they really love him. I mean, when he walks down this street, he could do no wrong, this quirky guy, you know, people love him. So yeah, we'll see what happens. These efforts have been underway in some capacity for years. And there's even an official organization called the Detroit Berlin Connection that works on these things. So yeah, we'll see what happens. These efforts have been underway in some capacity for years.
比底特律多得多。底特律仍然处于其复兴阶段的初期。所以这可能会发生，这是一个非常棒的概念，但这需要时间和大量资金，但你知道的，矩阵（指代德米特里），一个能想出点子的人，有些行得通，有些行不通，但当它们行得通时，确实很管用。底特律的本地人真的很喜欢他。我的意思是，当他走在这条街上时，他做什么都是对的，这个古怪的家伙，你知道，人们很喜欢他。所以，是的，我们拭目以待。这些努力以某种形式已经进行了多年。甚至还有一个名为“底特律-柏林连接”的官方组织在处理这些事情。所以，是的，我们拭目以待。这些努力以某种形式已经进行了多年。
And there's even an official organization called the Detroit Berlin Connection that works on these things. But whatever happens, the bond between the two scenes is still strong. One for example, lived in Berlin in 2018 for half a year because it makes sense with his DJing work. You can fly to London or Paris in just an hour or two, compare that with a whole day trip from Detroit. And Blake regularly visits Berlin
甚至还有一个名为“底特律-柏林连接”的官方组织在处理这些事情。但无论发生什么，两个场景之间的纽带依然牢固。例如，胡安在2018年在柏林住了半年，因为这与他的DJ工作很合拍。你只需一两个小时就能飞到伦敦或巴黎，相比之下，从底特律出发则需要整整一天的行程。布雷克经常访问柏林，
and at least in non-Cronotimes, DJs at Trezor several times a year. And actually it turns out that he has a daughter with the Mutri's daughter. Well, okay, they are close. Yeah, so there's the real Berlin Detroit connection for you. And so yeah, however you look at it, the 30 year connection that techno forged
并且至少在非疫情时期，每年都会在特雷佐做几次DJ。事实上，结果证明他和德米特里的女儿生了一个女儿。好吧，他们确实很亲密。是的，这就是真正的柏林-底特律联系。所以，是的，无论你怎么看，技术音乐在柏林和底特律之间建立的30年联系都将长存。
between Berlin and Detroit is here to stay. Well, that is so cool. Thank you so much for bringing this other aspect to the story, Kevin. I really appreciate it. Yeah, it was my pleasure, Roman. 99% Invisible Was Produced This Week by Kevin Caner's edited by our executive producer Delaney Hall, music by our director of sound, Sean Riel, mixed by Bryson Barnes.
嗯，这太酷了。非常感谢你把故事的这一方面带给我们，凯文。我真的很感激。是的，这是我的荣幸，罗曼。本周的《百分之九十九隐形》由凯文·卡纳斯制作，我们的执行制作人德兰尼·霍尔剪辑，音乐由我们的声音总监肖恩·里尔提供，混音由布赖森·巴恩斯完成。
Kurt Coles said is the digital director of the rest of the team, is Christopher Johnson, Lashemadon, Vivian Le, Joe Rosenberg, Katie Minkle, Emmett Fitzgerald, Chris Baroube, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. We are a part of the Stitcher and Sirius XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org, where on Instagram and Reddit
库尔特·科尔斯塔德是数字总监，团队的其他成员包括克里斯托弗·约翰逊、拉谢马·多恩、维维安·勒、乔·罗森伯格、凯蒂·明克尔、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯·巴鲁贝、索菲亚·克拉茨克，以及我罗曼·马尔斯。我们是Stitcher和Sirius XM播客家族的一部分，现在总部设在位于加利福尼亚州美丽的奥克兰市中心北部六个街区的潘多拉大楼。你可以在Facebook上找到本节目并参与讨论。你可以在Twitter上关注我@RomanMars，以及节目@99PI org，我们也在Instagram和Reddit上
too. You can find other shows I love from Stitcher on our website, 99pi.org, including The Dream. Season one is a brilliant investigation of multi-level marketing. Season two takes on the wellness industry. Search for it wherever you're listening now or follow our link at 99py.org. Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince Ince 6M. 2. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
活跃。你可以在我们的网站99pi.org上找到我从Stitcher上喜欢的其他节目，包括《梦想》。第一季是对多层次营销的精彩调查。第二季探讨了健康产业。无论你在哪里收听，都可以搜索它，或者通过99pi.org上的链接关注我们。目前这个剧集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。